so I'm going to start with like a little
bit of a game-like question I want to
play Hi-Lo with you I want a high from
the filming of Avatar the way of water a
day that went perfectly that made you
feel really good but then I also want a
low or a more challenging moment for you
to tell me how you overcame that low
um
I think so I mean there weren't many low
lows per se like terrible days how could
there be a terrible day on this set
honestly but
um highs
honestly as as a young actor just every
day just being there filming with
everyone with this Avatar family
Lowe's I remember there was one or two
days like maybe at the beginning of
filming at least in the tank where I
wasn't just scared I wasn't scared that
I wasn't safe or anything but I was
scared that I wouldn't be able to do a
good job
um underwater and uh gym and just the
crew and also my fellow cast members
just made me feel like I was doing a
good job and helped me be the best
knobby and took I could be you very much
were thank you have it for you hi and
hello hi and hello
um I think
my very first day was probably the high
because I was it was
um I was it was just I was with slang
and some some of the other cast and I
remember I just felt so confident and
they made me feel so confident and like
comfortable and I don't know it was just
so fun and um well so I guess spoiling
too much and then there were some full
face mask scuba days where I was in the
tank and I was underwater for hours on
end
and I just got a little claustrophobic
but I just I kept calm and
um you know I just you have to just I
pushed through it and you know here we
are so low is never a low because you
learn from those challenges and you take
those lessons with you and then you have
them in your back pocket for future
performances I was reading a lot about
how there were some really really long
takes done on this movie so can you
remember the longest one you did and was
that a challenge or do you find it
freeing oh this one of our longest takes
I think you have a scene I definitely
can't say if you want to say it we'll
brand this a spoiler review interview
and we'll run it after the movie comes
out oh this is this is not even until
so um oh
um and you can keep talking I don't mind
um I don't know all right it's something
in two
um
I don't know I feel like because being
in performance capture in The Sound
Stage a lot of scenes were long because
it felt like almost like theater because
you know Jim could
cut at any point so we just run the
whole scene and also we were just always
kind of playing and discovering and
because
um in performance capture we didn't have
to do one same take and like you said it
was like theater and we were yeah we
were all in it together maybe when the
recombs have us that was a lot just like
long takes but sometimes we would film
scenes for like a whole like one scene
for a whole day yeah
um or morning or stuff
um it was that process paid off
exceptionally well yeah you were getting
my only non-avatar question of the
entire day but I am a massive scream fan
I know you probably can't tell me
anything about that movie so maybe is
there anything about scream being your
first big horror franchise that looking
back on that shoot now makes you think
I'm so glad my first is with that
particular series of horror films oh um
well I'm a massive scream fan too so
jumping into scream was
um like I I mean I think like what made
me excited was just that scream was my
fate my my favorite horror slasher genre
there is so that was what's your
favorite film that's not your own
um the first one easy that's the right
answer oh yeah I know it's the best
answer because it's the best one it is
the best one yeah you can't top that